it's our next speaker second speaker is
andre
kraken i'm not sure i pronounced her
name correctly spoken
already so close enough uh he's uh
worked extensively on constraint
satisfaction problems csps which are a
generalized form of sat and that's of
interest to a
50 years of sat workshop of course
he's talking today on classifying the
complexity of sat and csp
are we there yet so please go ahead
thank you sam um so let's start uh of
course i will start from um
uh from where uh it all began from uh
schaefer's
paper 1978 where he um
looked at generalized statistical
ability problems
so they're just like sad but instead of
clauses you use relations
boolean relations of specified arity so
if
your gamma contains some relation say
r1 is a ternary relation r2 is a binary
relation and so on
then an instance of sub gamma looks like
this so
you take some tuples of variables
and apply your relations to them another
question
is where there is an assignment from the
variables to uh
zero and one that satisfies phi meaning
that uh
for every uh say uh the values of x y
and z
this triple belongs to r1 and so on
so the special cases of sat gamma are of
course case out problems because
clauses define relations horn cases are
the same it's a special case of facade
gamma
kalin linear equations
modulo 2 with at most k variables
well they of course they defined some
relations so well you could use those
to define your your problem and then
what you have
is the problem of solving systems of
linear equations more you or two
uh now what uh schaefer did um he
worked with gadgets so he defined
some relations from other relations by
gadgets so
let's say that a relation r is
expressible by a gadget
over your given set gamma if there is an
instance
phi which is drawn here
um offset gamma
such that r can be obtained as follows
you take you look at all solutions um to
your instance this is some relation
obviously
and then you choose some variables here
and project out all the rest so in this
case
your phi would use five constraints
all using relations from gamma it
uses nine variables and then you look at
all the
solutions uh to find that some relation
and then you project out all the
variables except for
x3 x5 and x7 so this is what it means to
express something by a gadget of course
uh
if you have your gamma and some r is
expressible by a gadget over
a gamma then you can add r to gamma
without changing the complexity of sat
gamma
right simply because every occurrence of
r can be replaced by this gadget in any
instance
okay so you can easily get rid of r
replace it by a gadget
over gamma and that's that was the key
notion
so what the uh schaeffer proved is that
if you take any
non-trivial gamma non-trivial means that
it's not true that every instance can be
satisfied by simply assigning
the same value to all variables so
that's what i call trigger
so if we have a non-trivial gamma then
exactly one of the following holes
either side gamma is a sub problem
of one of the uh known uh tractable
cases of sat such as tusad hornsat it's
dual or
systems of linear equations modulo 2
and when i say subproblem more exactly
this means that
every relation in gamma can be expressed
by a gadget
over the corresponding problem so for
two sat
that would be every relation in gamma
can be expressed as a conjunction of two
clauses
possibly with some uh variables
projected out
so this is one case uh you can be a
you are expressible by a gadget over
some tractable case
then you're tractable and the other case
is when you
you can express uh three sat by um
a gadget over gamma with additional
constant relations
and then sub gamma isn't be complete so
this idea of
expressing things by gadget uh is
important it will go throughout the talk
and we'll
get back to it many times okay
well in particular um from this theorem
it follows that uh the following two
problems are np-complete these are
special cases of south gamma
uh we will use them later one is called
one and three sat
and that's when what contains uh the
only relation
turn the relation uh like this
r one and three so that's one and three
side
and the other um problem is not all
equal sat
again it's a problem sub gamma where
gamma contains
a single ternary relation
are not all equal which contains all
triples of zeros and ones
except for all zeros and all ones so
while these are standard
now np complete problems that are used
in many cases
as a starting point for many reductions
but we'll get back to these standards
and pick up the problems later
so uh that was that was it 1978
question asked question answered that's
it
end of story right um
well this is what it looked like back
then
and then nothing much happened um in the
80s well some uh some things happened
in parallel in the parallel universe um
some considerations regarding graph
homomorphisms
so if you have two graphs g and h then
what's your homomorphism from g to h
what this is simply a mapping from the
vertices of g to the vertices of
h that preserves the edges if you have
an
edge in g then the images must
constitute an h an edge in the graph h
notice that if your graph h is a k clip
then this homomorphism such how morphism
is simply a k
coloring of g and this is why um
this generalization from coloring to
homomorphisms is called the h-coloring
problem
given um a graph g is there a
homomorphism
from g to h so of course for uh
k coloring it's uh it's it's been known
for a while that the problem is um
p complete uh it was known that for any
bipartite graph the problem uh
essentially reduces to two sides so uh
it would be a solvable polynomial time
and there were um other separate cases
uh
of unknown bipartite um graphs age where
the problem was known to be
complete so naturally there was a
question
about the general picture so what
happens if h is
any graph and this question was raised
by many researchers and eventually a
hell initiative will
resolve this and prove that for any
undirected graph h
the age coloring problem is solvable
polynomial time if h is bipartite or has
a loop
having a loop is a trivial case of
course so uh and in all other cases it
is np complete
uh well curiously um this famous paper
doesn't even cite
um sheffield's paper so clearly uh hell
natural
thought that they were they were doing
something completely different unrelated
to
schaefer's work well uh
not that uh this is a this turned out to
be the case
actually of course these problems are
related
um they are both special cases of the
constraint satisfaction problem and let
me define this problem now
so uh i will fix a relational structure
a which is simply a finite set a the
domain
of my structure and a finite set of
relations of
various rarities on the domain
then an instance of the deconstraint
instruction problem
with this structure a looks like this so
again we have some variables
and to some variables we apply the
constraint r1
to some other variables we apply the
constraint r2
and so on and the question is the same
as for generalized viability
is there an assignment uh from variables
to the domain
that satisfies this formula it satisfies
all constraints
so this problem was uh um considered
very very actively in uh in the
artificial intelligence community
this is actually where this particular
formulation came from
um so that was again a different
community that
didn't know anything about shaffer or
helen nichtrail
but the inside from uh theater vardy and
jevons
independently in the mid 90s was that
icsp can be considered as a homomorphism
problem
that's um providing a uniform framework
for all that this that happened in ai
or graphs or satisfiability
uh so uh how do you do it how do we do
this
um so let's um make a structure a new
relational structure i call it i for
instance
uh its base set will be variables these
are all the variables that appear
in um phi relation
uh corresponding to r1 contains all the
uh
tuples of variables that are constrained
by r1
the relation corresponding to r2 you can
see that they're color coded here
contains all the tuples of variables to
which r2 is applied
and so on and then satisfying
assignments
for the formula phi are precisely the
homomorphisms
from i to a what's how much is from i to
a
well it's a mapping from the domain of i
the variables to the domain of a which
is this set a
which preserves all the relations
meaning that every tuple here
is mapped into r1 every tuple here
is mapped into r2 and so on
so csp and the homomorphism problem for
relational structures
is the same thing this is what federer
vardy and germans observe
and then of course it's clear from this
that generalized sat and h coloring are
special cases of
of csp
um now um it was this paper uh by
theodoranvardi um
confidence version 93 journal version 98
that really put the csp
on on the map and made it known in
all of the theoretical computer science
community
so the main motivation uh for this paper
uh
was uh was this motivation find a large
largest natural subclass of np
that avoids intermediate problems so we
know from
loudness theorem that if p is not equal
to np
then np contains intermediate problems
neither polynomial time solvable
nor and p complete so what this question
asks is this that so what is the natural
class that avoids
all these and and intermediate problems
and um federer and vardy um naturally
used uh
logic to define another class uh so they
defined this complexity class called
msnp
so they took s and p s p is the
strict np so you take np and make a
syntactic restriction of it
called strict np which is contained in
p but it is equal to np up to polynomial
time equivalence
which means that for every problem in np
there is a polynomial time equivalent
problem in strict and p
so in particular if np contains
intermediate problems then strictly also
contain intermediate problems
um so feather and var you took this snp
and considered three restrictions uh for
it
monotone monadic and without
inequalities
i'm not going to define what these
restrictions mean
the point is this so if you take um
s p and apply not all three
of these um uh restrictions
but any two of them then we still have
that this class is equal to np
up to polynomial time equivalence
however if we impose all three
restrictions at once
then this is what we get this class
mmsnp
and what we can tell about it is that it
contains all the
uh csps
it strictly contains all csps but these
two classes
are again equal up to polynomial time
equivalence
okay so for every problem in mms and p
there is a polynomial time equivalent uh
csp
well actually in the original paper um
by fedor and vardy
one of these um reductions in the
equivalence was randomized
and it was later derandomized by kuhn
so um telling what he made
this dichotomy conjecture which says
that each problem in this class
each csp of a is either soluble in
polynomial time
or np complete in other words csps
cannot have
intermediate complexity in np and
clearly if we can prove this for csp
it follows that mms and p would also
have a dichotomy
p versus np complete
so well this was the main motivation of
feather and vardy but
this this paper is uh famous for many
reasons
and one of them is the reasons of ideas
and diversity of ideas in this paper
so uh i will just mention a few um so
one
idea was uh to introduce two general
types of
polynomial time algorithms that can be
used for csps
one algorithm well it is known by many
names and it is the most natural
algorithm you can invent for constraint
satisfaction problems
it is based on local propagation or its
logical version called data log
sometimes this is called the kl
algorithm
and this is how it goes you take your
instance
and then you take two integers k and l
um
so l should be a uh greater than or
equal to
uh k okay
and then you introduce a constraint for
each set of k variables in your instance
and this constraint initially allows all
possible combinations of values
and then you repeatedly solve
sub-instances with l variables one one
at a time
so once you you solve such sub-instance
uh you rule out some um assignments
of of um values to the variables
uh this is projected onto what the
relevant sets of k variables and so we
tighten the constraints on such
sets so this is kind of similar to or
maybe
resolution to some extent but the point
is that we
repeatedly tighten the constraints until
the situation is stable and then what
can happen
in the end is that we can rule out all
possible assignments of
values to some k tuple of variables
in which case of course the instance is
refuted and we output no and this
now is of course a correct answer
um if the in the
uh proceed procedure uh has stabilized
but we haven't refuted the instance this
means that the instance is now locally
consistent
and this case we answer yes of course
this yes answer
doesn't mean that uh the instance is
satisfiable
right this just means that it became
locally consistent without uh
the the instance so for some
um csps this actually is a solution
procedure
for some csps local consistency implies
global consistency
for some but not for all so i will
discuss this later again
and by the way this local propagation
algorithm can always use
a preprocessing for any instance you can
take any instance
and make it locally consistent in
polynomial time
again i will use this later so this was
the first type of algorithm the second
type of algorithm
was uh what they called subgroup
problems subgroup algorithms
so they thought that constraints would
be in this case
uh big uh cosets of the nth direct power
of some group
some group g and roughly the algorithm
goes like this
so you um introduce so you take your
constraints
and your instance into consideration one
by one so you add them one by one
you start with the first constraint c1
then you add the second constraint c2
and so on
and the algorithm processes those
instances
iteratively and at each step i
either the algorithm reports no solution
or it produces a representative
for phi i which is used um
in step i plus one
so this is roughly how it goes um
so uh um let me briefly briefly mention
some other selected insights
from this paper federer and vardy um
they observed that some closure
properties
seem to be somehow relevant um to a
tractability of csps they didn't make it
very precise or
took it very far they just observed that
there seems to be
something going on in this direction and
also simulation by gadgets is somehow
relevant
um so uh
and these properties closure properties
and simulation by gadgets
was something that was developed
independently and more or less at the
same time
by the group of fijians and his
co-authors
so one their insights was
like this so if we want to use gadgets
redux gadget reductions between csps
then actually we don't need explicit
gadgets
right so the only
we we need to know that they exist right
if we know gadgets exists we know um
we have reductions and say schaefer
used very explicit reductions uh sorry
very explicit gadgets in his reductions
but we don't actually need that um
so they asked this question is there a
general theory of gadget reductions
can we reason about the existence of
gadget reductions
without building gadgets explicitly
and their key observation was that
this is somehow related to things
previously studied in algebra
so let me give this definition on an
example
say say we have a graph h and then
an energy polymorphism of a graph h
is simply a homomorphism from the nth
power
of of age to itself
um so um what is a
an automorphism of a graph it's simply a
maping from
actually homomorphism from the graph to
itself which is bijective
that's an automorphism what's an
endomorphism
well it's just a homomorphism from the
graph to itself not necessarily by
jackie
just the homomorphism so this is
somehow a continuation of this line a
generalization of
endomorphism or automorphisms to uh
multivariable functions so
all polymorphisms of h are denoted like
this
and you can uh represent this
pictorially
so if you have some n edges
in h you have an edge from a1 to b1 from
a2 to b2
and so on from am to bn and then you
apply f to
one side of the edges you apply f to the
other side of the edges
and you get again two elements in age
and there must be an edge between them
so this is what it means uh to have a
polymorphism of a graph
and this extends in a natural way uh
to um say ternary relations right you
just need to uh
uh to do it like this and then here you
would have
so you um if you take and triples in
your ternary relation
and then apply your f component wise
the result must also be in the relation
so in this way we can generalize uh
this notion of a polymorphism to
arbitrary energy relations
and then to relational structures by
simply saying that
you must have a polymorphism of every
relation present in your structure
so the meaning of this is that
polymorphisms are higher dimensional
symmetries
so if you if we view automorphisms as
symmetries that endomorphism also
symmetries that are not necessarily
bijective so uh polymorphisms are also
symmetries but higher dimensional ones
and it's very important because they
carry important information about
your structure your graph that is not
contained
in the automorphism group or in the
morpheus monoid
the key property of polymorphisms is
that they compose
meaning that if you take two
polymorphisms
say you have g oops um
g of uv and you have another ternary
polymorphism f and you
uh compose them like this so you form
say a foray function like this then this
function would also be a polymorphism so
you can
build polymorphisms larger polymorphisms
from smaller polymorphisms
by using composition
so this is the key theorem that relates
polymorphisms and gadget reductions
uh that was proved by jevons and his
co-authors in 1997 roughly building on
some
earlier developments in algebra by
bonner chubb code of
collusion and roma and geiger
independent uh
works so what this theorem says is that
if you have
two structures with the same domain
then the following things are equivalent
there is a gadget reduction
from here from the first csp to the
second csp
and the polymorphisms
of the second csp are also polymorphisms
of the first csp
so it goes the the opposite way the more
polymorphisms
the easier the problem
um so what in particular
so uh this theorem says that uh the
existence of gadget reductions
is controlled by polymorphisms okay
and if you take the special case of this
theorem
when actually paul a prime
is equal to pole a then this theorem
says
that csp of a and csp of a prime
have gadget reductions going both
directions
right so if you want to reason about
their computational complexity
then you don't have any reason to
distinguish them
right if they have the same
polymorphisms then they have the same
complexity
so it makes sense to reason about the
complexity of csps
through polymorphisms because then you
can capture
classes of equivalent problems at once
so this was uh the notion of gadget
reduction
pretty much the same as used by schaefer
for this you need uh that the structures
have the same domain
uh in fact this notion can be a
generalized to
relations on different domains when a
uses one domain and a prime uses
a different domain um this is a sort of
a generalization
but it's it's very natural again this is
what you would call gadget steel
and uh uh bringing it fast forward a
little bit
this result by uh bartholomew
says that there is this general more
general gadget reduction
from cspa to cspa prime if and only if
instead of containment
uh of poly prime in paul a
you have something called immediate
homomorphism
so uh i won't explain what it is exactly
but you can think of it as containment
on the abstract level
so that you can you can use it to uh
talk about
polymorphisms uh on different defining
different sets
so this is somehow similar to what when
you
go from permutation groups
to abstract groups right on permutation
groups
you can talk about uh inclusion of one
group in the other
but then for this you need that uh these
permutation groups act on the same set
right if you want to talk about
homomorphism from one group to the other
then they don't have to be on the same
set so this homomorphism group how more
is an abstract notion which is somehow
more general than uh set wise inclusion
so this is what's going on here uh
again the important point is that we
know exactly
when gadgets gadget reductions work
um now um let me discuss
very briefly what we can call trivial
symmetries trivial polymorphisms and
non-trivial symmetries
so uh if we look at polymorphisms of any
structure
this set of polymorphisms then it always
contains
uh the seti of trivial polymorphisms
these are the energy operations of very
simple form
like this so it's an energy operation it
takes an
n-tuple and outputs the i-argument
so they're called projections or
sometimes they're called dictators
in a different community so very simple
functions
they don't do anything they just output
the i argument that they get
so what why do i call such polymorphisms
trivial because
they are present everywhere every
structure has them
so uh having such polymorphisms doesn't
tell you anything at all
because every structure has them but
curiously uh some structures
have only such polymorphisms so for
example if you look at three cells and
the corresponding
structure that gives a threesat as a csp
then it has only such polymorphisms only
trivial polymorphisms and nothing else
and this is a relatively easy exercise
you can
you can do it um you know on your own on
a napkin in
five 15 minutes and i'm not showing off
it's really
very simple and elementary
all you need is the definition and
that's it
so um now um if we again
go back to the previous slide and look
at this condition
that uh paul a has some kind of
homomorphism to
this set of trivial polymor or trivial
functions
then this exists if and only if there is
a gadget reduction
going the other way from threesat which
is the
csp corresponding to this to csp of a
so this happens if and only if again
we have a gadget reduction from 3sat to
our csp
so in this case of course the csp would
be np complete
so we can take this condition to mean
that
the symmetries of a polymorphisms of a
are trivial on the abstract level so
they're like projections they
don't have to be exactly that but on the
abstract level they behave exactly the
same way
so this is what i would i will call
trivial
right there's a question the chat k
sat has only trivial polymorphisms yes
if k is at least three
two sat has not revealed polymorphisms
for example
the ternary majority operation on the
boolean domain
is a polymorphism of tucson but threesat
and
all the other case ads have only trivial
polymorphisms
can i ask a question also uh a sub 3 sat
there what
that's a structure i'm not sure what
that is well uh
three thought you can um so you see if
you use the homomorphism view
then uh what you need is a relational
structure that has a relation
for every type of constraint that can
appear in threesat
okay threesat can have what
four types of clauses right involving
non-negation
one negation two negations three
negations
so these are the four relations that you
would have in this structure
corresponding to three
sides thank you
okay good
so uh right now these are the trivial
symmetries so uh what made symmetries
non-trivial to prevent uh this condition
to prevent that
we have a gadget reduction from threesat
well i will sort of hand way through
this on an example
so that this thing is a minion how
morphism whatever it is
uh but what it does is that it preserves
solutions to systems of equations
so what do i mean by that so let's look
at
at this and think of
this as an equation where f
is an unknown function so f is an
unknown function
it has n variables and what we know
about
f is that if we identify
all variables in f
except for one
right then we get a binary function
depending on x and y
and this function will be the same
regardless of where this
soul y is okay
so this is an equation um
where the variable is f right it's the
it's the unknown so it's a system of
equations
which you want to solve in your set of
functions
right so if you either you have in your
set of functions
a function f satisfying this or you
don't
so one this minion homorphism preserves
solutions to systems of equations which
means that uh
if you have uh if this system
is solvable here so if a has a
polymorphism
like this then t would also contain a
function
that satisfies this system of equations
but this cannot be the case look at this
can this system of uh equations
be satisfied in projections so the
question is
can we find a projection p
which we can uh substitute for f and get
equalities everywhere
now if f is the projection sorry if
p is a projection of the first variable
so well
let's look can the projection the first
variable be the solution
well then uh this would return y and
this would return x
so these would be different functions
right this function
is a binary function that always returns
y and this would be the binary function
that always return x
so they are different functions uh
can f be the projection the second
variable
no because we just look again at this y
and say it is x so it's impossible well
you probably get how how this goes uh
so f if it's uh so we that's what i'm
trying to say is that
there is no solution to this system of
equations in projections
you cannot find the projection
satisfying all these equations
and this means uh in particular that you
don't have
this median homomorphism so that
threesat
there is no reduction there is no gadget
reduction from 3sat
to your csp
so uh this is what it what it's about
right
systems of equations satisfiable or not
satisfiable in your symmetries
this is what determines how strong your
symmetries are
um now let me move on and um
look at um structural universal algebra
which is somehow the next step uh from
what jevons did
by uh bringing uh some kind of a
universal algebra
uh into the csp business so structural
theory of universal algebras is an
independent uh
field it's a very deep theory that was
actively developed from 1950s with lots
of very very deep results
but it's somehow it's not very widely
known um
it's not groups it's uh considered
generally more esoteric
despite the sheer strength of the
results uh that were obtained in this
theory
and somehow generally this is uh
considered by computer scientists as a
deep dark wood you don't want to go
there
unless you have a local guide or maybe
even in this case you don't want to go
so the general theory of gadget
reductions
is a simple thing you can somehow
intuitively understand what this means
right one problem gadget reduces to
another if and only if something happens
but uh this structural theory of
universal algebras that's a
um that's really deep thing um
so it was the connection uh between csp
and uh this theory
was somehow made very explicit and clear
in a series of papers by uh bullard of
germans and myself
and in particular um
there we are observed that um if your
structure a if your csp has only trivial
symmetries
then csp isn't complete
and we made this um conjecture which
was called the algebraic csp dichotomy
conjecture
that says that uh in all the other cases
which means if a has any non-trivial
symmetries
then csp of a is solvable in polynomial
time
so what this is the refinement of the
feather body conjecture because it
specifies where the boundary is
on the boundary uh well it's very simple
trivial symmetries
means threesat reduces to your problem
by gadgets
non-trivial symmetries means that there
is some substructure
in your problem which you can use
to provide a polynomial time algorithm
well of course uh that's uh that's hard
it's not nerve that's not easy it's a
it's just some non-trivial symmetries
what does this mean
maybe you can have some very weak
non-trivial symmetries
uh well um this conjecture was actually
confirmed
in some important special cases by
vulata for example
for for the case one a has a three
element domain
or when all human relations are
available
and actually uh there were very many
mutually beneficial
developments between csp and universal
algebra
in particular um a series of papers for
example by mackenzie and mariotti and
barton kojic
prove that if you have some non-trivial
symmetries that actually have very
strong symmetries
there is some kind of algebraic
dichotomy there
you don't have just a moderately weak
non-trivial symmetries either you have
trivial symmetries or strong
which was excellent of course so there
are there are two main algorithmic ideas
for csps one
is just the same as federer vardy local
propagation
so again the no answer
delivered by local propagation is always
correct the yes answer is not always
correct
but for some csps it is always correct
and
the full description of when this works
was given by uh
barton kojic the other idea
um evolved quite a bit from um
federer and vardy uh so it's somehow
similar but um
more general so again you take your
instance and you throw in constraints
one by one
c1 then c1 c2 then c1 c23 and so on
and then um you iteratively uh compute
a small polysize generating set
for these instances so you start from c1
you get a generating uh set for for just
c1 just this one constraint
then you have this generating set you
add c2 and from
x1 and c2 you compute x2
a small generating set for these guys
then
you have x2 and you add c3 and you
compute x3 from there
and so on and then in the end you have
xn
which is a small generating set for the
solution
set of the whole instance which is
either empty in which case you have no
solution
or it's not empty in which case you have
solutions in fact you have
even some representation for the whole
set of solutions
and again uh there was a a full
characterization of when this algorithm
works because of course
not always you have such small
generating sets
uh and when you do have them you can
actually compute them in polynomial time
so ejac mckenzie marotti valerio and
willard
fully characterized when this fusa
powers
algorithm works and then all these
eventually led to the resolution of the
federal army conjecture
by uh bulatov and zhuk independently in
1917
so 2017. so i will very briefly uh
discuss the algorithms of blood of
andrew
they are very similar on a very very
high level but all the details are
different
so both algorithms are heavily used um
some forms of local propagation
different forms and in bulatov's case
it's not even
very local um both algorithms are
recursive
and they use a range of different um
rules for
reducing instances or splitting
instances in several parts
and then once you're using your instance
you take it as
the starting instance and start from
that you recurse
so the base cases for recursion roughly
are the follows
well if all the domains of all variables
are reduced to a singletons
then you just have a solution if some
domain
is empty then you have no solution
um in blood of water's case
one of the um base cases was one
diffuser power sulfate
from the previous slide is applicable so
if you if you have this case then you
just apply the algorithm and get the
answer
and in shook's case it was systems of
linear equations over that p
so of course the key part of both
results
is the description of those data
reduction rules
how you can reduce your instance how you
can split your instance
and the proof that these
these rules always reduce in polynomial
time to one of the base cases
so this is roughly um how the algorithms
work well um so
again goal reached
um conjecture confirmed and in fact we
mentioned um in very many papers uh that
um
this is the main motivation of this
whole um
direction of research so this is what we
this is the ultimate goal
and somehow we made the impression that
uh this is our only goal
so we achieve that and that's it we can
all retire
um but somehow uh even in the process
when the
somehow the community was approaching
the resolution of this conjecture
a different motivation
started playing a more more more
important role
and this motivation is is this so we
don't just
don't just want to say here are the uh
tractable problems here are the np
complete problems we want to know
exactly why these problems
are tractable and be complete we want to
know the structure
so in general i think this is one of the
general goals of theoretical computer
science
to understand what is the infinite
mathematical structure
in the um tractable problems
so destructible problems they are
polynomial time solvable because they
have some
some intrinsic mathematical structure
what is this structure can we
somehow explain it uh in in
in some very general way so this was a
very strong driving force behind this
direction
and from this point of view of course
this result is very significant
it's one with the most significant
results deservedly
but we want to know more
we want to know the same
say the reason behind uh tractability
for other problems not just csps or
maybe more general csps
so essentially we know very little about
the structure
of efficient computation the
mathematical structure of it
and we want to know more
so uh that that's the uh the dominant
motivation
uh for this line of research now so uh
as we were approaching as the community
uh the resolution of the federal
conjecture some other problem was
somehow
lurking in the background and making
some noises
and that's the approximate graph
coloring problem
so the classical fact is that um if you
are given a k
colorable graph then it's in it's np
hard to find a k coloring for it
so this follows uh trivially of course
right you just run
so if you assume that this task is
polynomial time solvable
then you just run your algorithm on
whatever
input graph you get and you check the
answer if the answer is a k
coloring then your graph is k colorable
if your answer
is something else then your assumption
about
key colorability was false and geography
is not key colorable
so so that was a pretty uh pretty easy
and that was known for ages since the
early 70s probably so the natural
question is this
okay so you cannot find the k coloring
now how many colors do you need to
efficiently find the coloring
and here's the state of the art for
three colorable graphs
so here these are the best known results
so the positive result is this
uh we need um roughly
n to the power one fifth colors where n
is the number of vertices in the graph
so it's not even a constant it's some
function it's a polynomial function in a
number of vertices
that's the the best positive result that
we have by kawarabayashi and thor
the best negative result that we have is
that finding a five coloring
for a three colorable graph isn't bihar
so the state of the art was that uh
finding a three coloring
wasn't big hard that was uh from the 70s
until
roughly 2000 when it was
improved to a four coloring by a kalai
uh safra and
lineal and then
so 15 or or 20 years later it was
improved to five
by uh uh barto bulin um myself and
openshaw
so you can see the gap between uh the
negative and the positive
uh results that we have and that this is
not a random problem right this is a
graph coloring problem this is something
that uh
we as a community studied for for ages
and what this shows is that uh we do not
understand
the mathematical structure of this
problem we just don't understand it
at all right because we have such a huge
gap
um right so one
it was a suggest suggested i think even
by gary and johnson in the 70s
that um this uh this isn't big heart uh
given a k
colorable graph uh finding a c coloring
for it
isn't bihar for any constant c
uh this problem is largely open uh
actually this was shown to be true under
some assumptions
which are not like unique which are like
unique games conjecture but not quite
some variation of unique games
conjecture and state of the art is this
um
so coloring um c coloring
a k colorable graph isn't p um hard
if c is uh 2k minus one
that's again from this ambi bko paper
and uh this uh cow's paper by myself
opera shal
uh rochna and jivny uh proved uh
the same result for this number c
so for very small numbers k such as uh
three and four this is better for i
think for five
they give the same number for starting
from six
the second one is much better gives a
much stronger result
okay um now i'm motivated by this um um
austrian
um guru swami and hostart started this
um
promise problem so this approximate
graph coloring is a promise problem
right
your promise that your graph is k
colorable do something with it
um a promised version of uh
satisfiability was considered by
austrian guruswamy and husted and it was
called two plus epsilon sat so we just
define
g k sub with two parameters as follows
you have an instance of k
out and you have a promise that you have
there is an assignment
you don't have it but there is one that
satisfies
at least g literals in which clause
okay so if g is two then you are
guaranteed to have an assignment that
satisfies
not just one but at least two literals
in every clause
and the goal is to find some normal
satisfying assignment
so what they uh proved is that this
problem is polynomial time solvable
uh if k over g is at most two in this
case you can use a randomized uh two
start algorithm for volumetrio
or use a nope relaxation to get um
a randomization not in the randomized
algorithm
and as long as k over g goes over 2
the problem becomes and p hard and hence
2 plus epsilon sat
so uh these are clearly problems of the
same um
of the same type and both are
tuples epsilon sat and approximate graph
coloring both are
csps so one can define a promiscsp
problem
as follows so you have two one
structures a and b and basically a
solution in a
guarantees you a solution in b
uh so then the problem is defined like
this so you have two
cases you have your instance either it's
satisfiable in a
or not satisfiable even in b so on the
picture it looks like this
it's a promise problem so you have
something in the middle that you don't
care about
and you need to distinguish between the
two cases that's the decision version
you can also look at the search version
when you are given um an instance and
you know it has a solution in a you need
to find a solution
b so there is a reduction from decision
to search
but the other direction is open and this
problem pcsp for a and b is the
generalization of csp of a because if a
and b
are equal then what you get is just csp
of a so
it's a vast generalization and if one of
these two problems csp of a or csp or b
soluble polynomial time
then you can of course solve this of
that
and hence the whole ptsp is solvable
polynomial time
so what this problem is interesting when
both csp of a and csp of b
are np heart problems so and then we
have a
new goal to classify all those so let me
tell you briefly what happens in the
boolean case so
if we look at one and three start and
not all equal sat which are the
well-known and p-heart problems
then the corresponding pcsp is actually
solvable in polynomial time
if i give you an instance of three three
one threesat
and i can guarantee that uh it has a
satisfying assignment
then it will be hard to find such an
assignment
but you can find in polynomial time and
not an equal
satisfying assignment for your instance
but here's the algorithm
you replace every one and three
constraint by a linear equation x plus y
uh plus z equals one that's of course a
relaxation
you solve the obtained three linear
system of reset which you can do in
polynomial time
and then you round your solution for the
system so you
map all positive things to one one all
non-positive things to zero
so if you're system was so if your one
in three instances was satisfiable
then of course this uh would still be a
satisfying
um a solution for the linear system
and then of course uh if you look at
your equation then you can see
that in this solution to your linear
system
you cannot have all x y and z positive
or all of them non-positive
right you cannot have that all these x y
and that are positive
because the sum must equal to one and if
they're all non-positive then the sum
cannot equal to one either which means
that this rounding gives you a solution
to the
not only equal side and actually there
are some
dichotomies now for boolean csps with
symmetric relations only not general
dichotomy
um so let me just tell you that this
theory of gadget reductions has been
extended
from csps to pcsps and applied
successfully i need to
wrap up of course so um
let me um
just uh fast forward uh and tell you uh
that uh
for promise graph homomorphism so i i
told you that you know for boolean csps
we know some dichotomies but there are
many cases that are open
you can have a promised version of age
coloring
and again some something is known about
this version but there are many many
open questions
um so uh the national question is
is there a dichotomy for pcsps like um
like the one for csps
i think it's too uh too early to predict
so what we know is that uh
pcsp pcsps is all about symmetries it's
all about abstract properties of
polymorphisms
the difference is that this time
polymorphisms act from one set to
another set
so you cannot even compose them which
implies that
even though the general theory of
reductions
works structural universal algebra is
not applicable
so you need to do something else
for csps we have this very convenient
property that either you have
trivial symmetries or very strong
symmetries
what you have for pcsps is that you can
have
limited nontrivial uh symmetries which
would give you hardness
or you can have strong enough symmetries
that give you an efficient algorithm
so but the question is is there a gap
between limited non-trivial and strong
enough
we don't know that's an open question
this is something to work on
and of course we need more evidence uh
to even conjecture this dichotomy so for
example
classification for all boolean pcsps
generalizing shaffer
or classification for promised graph
homomorphism generalizing
unnatural would be good now of course
sorry classification for promised
graphomorphisms
involves resolving this approximate
graph coloring conjecture
right which top people in approximation
try to resolve
for 40 years and couldn't so it's not
going to be a pushover right it needs
some
some new ideas and i believe we do have
new ideas
so let me summarize let me summarize
this promise csp is the fast
generalization of fine domain csp
and it includes some famous open
problems as special cases
so we have an extended abstract theory
of gadget reductions
for it and we have somehow a fresh broad
view on things
we have new algorithms which are somehow
infinite
like both algorithms of bulatov and zhuk
they're very finite they operate with
finite objects
for pcsps we have cases where probably
um
we need infinite algorithms such as
involving uh
relaxations linear programming
relaxations uh
find integer relaxations and uh such
like
to solve finite problems so we must use
infinite algorithms
we have new connections for example this
connection with topology
that we use to resolve some cases of
promised graph homomorphism
so this is all very interesting and then
we can use this fresh broad
view to look back on the existing csp
results such as the resolution of the
economy results
sorry the resolution of the economic
conjecture which is currently
uh not accessible to almost
everybody so can we somehow use
infinite ideas to provide a different
algorithm that will be more accessible
or maybe even explain uh the nature of
tractability better
looking forward we can try and explain
the general mathematical structure of
tractable
pcsps some general properties that
explain it on some
very general level and looking even more
forward
we can look beyond csps and the family
and use this idea
of high dimensional symmetries of
solution spaces to provide
general uniform explanations of
traceability
in some wider wider families of problems
so um there's a question in the chat to
explain relation to topology
so maybe let me finish and then i'll
explain it
so uh to wrap up this complex request
for pcsps it's big
important and wide open and i asked this
question uh
in the beginning of my talk are we there
yet and i believe the answer looks more
or less like this
we conquered a mountain but we found a
range
of even higher and uh
more interesting mountains so this is
where we are at the moment
all right thank you very much that was a
really great talk taking us all the way
from the very beginnings up to the
modern times so appreciate that
and i'll clap for everybody here as
usual uh we had a question as you noted
already from oliver coleman
uh in the chat window um
yes so the relation to topology uh
is is like this so you want to analyze
your polymorphisms um
say from a node cycle to another out
cycle say
c3 so your polymorphism is a
function of many variables
and you somehow you want to uh
derive that only few of the coordinates
in your function
are really important and all the rest is
kind of noise
so uh what you have is a discrete
function
but then you can make every graph into a
topological space
as is a standard procedure in
topological combinatorics
that was originated by allah in the 70s
and then every polymorphism becomes
a continuous map so if you have a um
if you have a direct product of a few
odd cycles so every old cycle of course
becomes just a circle
a direct product of odd cycles becomes
anantorus
and then what you want to analyze is a
mapping from your antorus
to a circle and you can do that
by using a topological means and then
from that
you somehow derive some information
about your original
uh polymorphism which is just you know a
map from a power of a note cycle
to one to a triangle this is how it goes
roughly
thanks do you have some names um
of people working on the topology link
yes my name
so this link is is brand new um
it was brought out in a paper by um
myself opera shall vrockner and jivny
and it's
a brand new paper from last year
very good um let's see i have a question
while waiting for the people to
come up with theirs um so
on the algebraic csp dichotomy uh
you mentioned the the bullatube and zuk
result in the
positive case where there are things r
and p what is the complexity of these
problems is it similar to
uh say sap or where well
or like linear time or something very
simple or you get complex algorithms
well i'm not even entirely sure that
there was a
a strong attempt to somehow bring this
complexity to some reasonable level uh
it's yeah i think the algorithms as they
are
have very very high polynomial
complexity
it's uh yeah it's nothing like you want
to see
is there any reason to suspect that's
inherent or
i'm not so sure that's because they uh
work with the uh somehow the uh the the
structure of the problem
the algebraic structure of the problem
and you know maybe there are some very
different approaches very different
algorithms that just don't do this
for example the algorithms that i
somehow alluded to
you know that are based on relaxations
to
infinite sets like you know lp and uh
maybe some lp hierarchy maybe
a fine integer relaxation something like
this
so uh i i'm not sure whether this is
infinite or
it's just the feature of the approach
and i'm pretty sure they they didn't try
to
reduce this complexity they just wanted
to work to get it done
okay good thank you
i have a question yes hi
andre so the question is in these
reductions where you prove the hardness
of
two k minus one coloring three colorable
graphs
uh the reduction uh is what is the
dependence on k
the running time of the reduction is it
is the k going in the exponent or is it
polynomial in
mk
oh well yeah i want you to think about
this i i
yeah i'm not sure we want to make
everybody wait
okay but the reason i ask this is
because i wonder what of the difficulty
is that um growing case
are making the problem so for example
could it be that
by allowing sub exponential algorithms
you can do better than than
this very bad gap of end to the one
phase
you see uh yeah that's a possibility of
course yeah
that's a possibility
six okay
all right some may ask a question yes
please go ahead
andre thank you very much for this
beautiful and informative talk first of
all
i was a bit surprised at the end you
seem to be negative about universal
algebra
helping you with the premise problems it
sounds to me more like universal
universal algebra as we know it or as
you know it because you know so much
more about it
why can't you think of um extensions of
or modifications or generalizations of
universal algebra that will
allow you to manipulate the symmetries
does it make sense yes of course yeah
thank you [ __ ] um
so um well basically the answer is this
um
um
in the ordinary csp you have functions
defined on the same domain so you can
compose them
and this gives you a lot of power
so um you can start with some some small
polymorphisms and
compose them in tricky ways and obtain
something very useful
um and that's somehow this is this is um
very important for for universal algebra
uh being able to
to do that somehow if you if you cannot
do this actually i i
discuss this with a few universal
algebraics and
i was somehow trying to suggest the same
that it seems it may be not completely
irrelevant
and basically they thought this was
heresy right if you cannot compose
functions
there is no universal algebra okay
um something is applicable to some
extent
but not not the structural um stuff
all right thank you like we do have this
uh theory of
um gadget reductions that still works
and
that's still pretty algebraic so maybe
maybe maybe your topology is the answer
the substitute to that i mean yeah yeah
thank you okay
good any other
questions
uh yes there's a question in the window
from aunt nina
do you think there's a dichotomy between
csps np
and nl like in schaefer's theorem
uh that's a good question yeah thank you
actually this is something
that's not completely resolved about
csps
um so even a characterization in an l um
it's um so that uh there are some um
some negative results and some positive
results and there is a tiny gap between
them for an l
which is still not closed and a
description of csps in an l would
automatically imply a description of
csps in l
by result of custom
so um i'm not sure about
the dichotomy as in schaefer's theorem
actually because there is also this
case of systems of linear equations
which of course have their own
complexity class
and it's not clear it's not clear how
this complexity class relates to an l
so you can have some a kind of um
not the coding button tetra cotton or
whatever kotami
but it will it will still have some
some uncertainty because we don't know
um
how the how solving uh linear equations
relates to an l
this this is this is open
so something can't be done but we would
have more more cases
so hopefully this answers the question
nothing
all right oh another question thomas
scott has a comment
question so stricter csps could be
represented by more course topology
[Music]
well it's a very general remark uh
i you know i i cannot say that this is
the main idea
i i wouldn't be able to uh to put the
main idea in um
in one line like that
okay i think
the main idea is that uh topology uh
somehow
represents um the uh homomorphism better
because
um you have um now if you say if you
have a like
okay coloring then you have many uh
colorings say maybe
10 colorings of k4
and you can move between between them
and this movement somehow corresponds to
what you can do with continuous
transformations
so somehow topology uh reflects the fact
that
you can switch between different uh
homomorphisms from a to b
you can transform one into another
say via aerial coloring
and this recoloring is is a somehow
topological process
i don't know if this makes much sense
so does this mean that the connectivity
of the solution space is relevant
uh maybe not not necessarily
connectivity but some some other
topological properties
or maybe you know in topology there are
many connectivities on different levels
interesting
so what is homeomorphism then
regarding this on the
topological side if you
can you say uh algebraic homomorphism
can be transformed into homomorphism
maybe
um just an idea
um well again i'm not so sure sorry
okay okay well there's no other
questions or comments i guess we'll wrap
things up thank you again for the
very thorough talk very nice and thank
you everyone for attending and we'll
see you guys here next week and there's
a fellows talk in about 15 20 minutes as
well
if you're interested in that you might
check it out so thank you again
thank you thank you